we're sending more troops overseas
President Obama spoke to Bob Schieffer
on CBS's Face the Nation yesterday
saying the decision to double the number
of troops in Iraq a quote sends or
signals rather a new phase he also said
and I'm quoting here what hasn't changed
is our troops are not going to be
engaged in combat is honestly well you
know what he's practicing is what we saw
in the Vietnam War in this gradual
escalation him being dragged every step
of the way remember for he always begins
or used to what telling everybody
including our enemies what we're not
going to do then he says we're not going
to have any boots on the ground and then
we're going to have some boots on the
ground but not many and then we're going
to have more boots on the ground but
don't worry they're not being going to
be in combat I mean it's step by step by
step and by the way these air strikes
are pinprick airstrikes they're not
going to change the equation on the
battlefield he said we're going to first
we're going to to forgotten exact words
but you know and destroy Isis we're not
going to destroy Isis with these kind of
tactics you need boots on the ground not
combat not the combat units but you need
people who will be exposed to combat the
form of Eric Ford air controllers
Special Forces trainers of the Iraqis
you need a lot if you're going to defeat
Isis and the longer we wait the Moors
Isis solidifies its position and by the
way controlling an area larger than the
state of Indiana and for us to have one
conflict in Syria and one in Iraq of
course is the height of insanity do you
think Isis respects the boundary between
Iraq and Syria of course not this is
this is a failed feckless foreign policy
national security policy that
unfortunately has put we lost four
thousand brave Americans in Iraq
and we had it stabilized but he had to
pull everybody out it was stabilized and
if we'd left a stabilizing force it
would have seen stayed that way now
we're paying a price that unfortunately
those who sacrificed unfortunately to
some degree where we're in vain that's
certainly a tragedy but what do you say
to those who say you know what we can't
look like we're going in there again
where the Americans going in and
fighting Islamic state it needs to be
this sort of organic movement that's
coming even if it isn't organic from
within not from the US well my only
point to them is that we can't win
without having a much more significant
involvement you know in previous Wars we
used to have numerous airstrikes
previous conflicts whether it be Desert
Storm whatever you're looking at we are
sometimes many of our sorties are
returning back not having dropped their
weapons because we don't have anybody on
the ground to identify the enemy you've
got to have people on the ground and
you've got to train these people and
you've got to do whatever is necessary
if you're going to defeat Isis and if
you don't want to defeat Isis fine but
most of us think that Isis is a direct
threat to the United States over time at
least that's what they say mmm so now
we're just having sort of half an
approach in your expected role as a
chair of the Senate Armed Services
Committee what what do you want to be
doing what do you want to accomplish we
want to have a strategy that is driven
by what our threats to our national
security are not by the budget we want
the strategy to drive the budget rather
than the budget to drive the strategy
and the sequestration which is harmed
our military so much has to be repealed